hey everyone Peter of Combofiend roses
here to break down some of the stuff
you're gonna see in Omega mode so as you
may have or may not have heard Omega
mode is the brand-new free fun and
awesome addition that we're bringing to
Ultra Street Fighter 4 it's gonna
definitely just be awesome set of new
moves per character characters have been
readjusted you know they play
differently they move faster or some
have some awesome new moves some have
some awesome new properties but you know
just talking about it it really doesn't
explain what you're gonna see so what
I'm gonna do is gonna give you a quick
breakdown of four of the world warrior
characters I mean I just sat down with
it for a few minutes this is what I
could find of course you guys will find
more once it gets into your hands but
let me let me just show you some of the
changes alright so let me start with Ken
you know so you'll notice here when you
go to the character selection you'll see
the addition ultra now let's go one more
to a mega mega mode pick him and I'll be
going up against Abel because evil is
one of the best training dummies in this
whole game so let's see he'll pick
doesn't matter and I'm just gonna show
you how ken is a bit different tell me
if you could spot the differences you
know I'm not gonna really talk for a few
seconds I'm just gonna show you stuff so
uh let's see
and then let's see if I get close oh
it's two hits it's one hit look at this
guy you see do you see that movement
hold on hold on get a taste of that so
you know Kenneth's are already already
looking extravagant Oh are these these
SDKs oh you know they didn't give it to
him did they they did let's see if I yes
what happens so I'm gonna stop right
there
I just wanted to give you guys a quick
snippet I mean once you guys get in your
hands you can show me what kind of crazy
stuff you guys could come up with so
that's Ken Ken at the most top level
that you could see only you let me pick
another world warrior guys out of the
original heat so we went for Ken let's
see who else is popular
I like dial dial with so you know I'm
just gonna go through the specials see
see if they're different see if you
could spot the differences you know I
mean I might not be able to keep my hype
so I mean I might be giving it away
look at this movement Oh Remy kicks
now you just see that I might have to
have Hans
edit that out that's too serious what
else does this guy have fire bowling
over the top
oh man all right all right all right
this is the X version Oh No let's see
here all right so right now
guile has an awesome new array of
specialist he has these flashes movement
car a flash kick something awesome
oh no let me stop all right well I mean
you guys got a teasing style I don't
know if you guys are ready it this is
pretty up options
Oh No alright alright alright alright
next character next character guys only
giving you guys a sneak peek you know I
don't what the suits coming down to
harder because I'm exposing all this
madness see sim yeah why now let's try
sim because you know a lot of people say
that simp isn't as strong as he could be
so let's just check out this one I'll
just stay with evil you know perfect
training dumb this guy has in store for
you and I ready for that
oh wait let's go rush downtown let's see
what else do we have here it's kind of
serious what does he have yoga stare get
over here the launcher
oh wait oh I'm gonna airport state hot
alright well let me give you a sample of
one more character of course you guys
know it has to be the strongest woman in
the world
shun we see what she has in store for
you guys this is pretty wild guys it's
pretty wild all and then just imagine
this is all 44 characters that have been
redone not just these four that I'm
showing you there's still 40 more you
guys gotta get your hands on so let's
see let's see you know the spin out okay
commands okay alright
see what else do we got here pretty
interesting what about the e^x version
old flashbacks I know you guys out there
saw that
loulou that's that's pretty well this
pretty well guys let's see what else do
we have here pretty awesome so Chumley
see her because I'm not charging them so
Chumley looking like she has a new
arrange of it this is amazing and as I
said guys this is just the beginning of
what you can expect to see in a mega
mode it'll be released a little bit
later this year guys and all 44
characters have been redone we're
talking about new moves we're talking
about new properties they might play
faster they might play slower they might
play like a version that you may have
wanted them to play like like a previous
iteration who knows what kind of changes
they've got just wait for it and once
again it's coming from us it's free and
I want to let you guys know that we are
gonna continue our support for Twitter
Street Fighter 4 because we want to make
sure that this is the definitive version
so thanks for watching guys stay tuned
for more information check back to
Capcom fighters and also check back at
the Capcom unity thanks guys